first things first I do not wear hair
extensions I never have I have grown my
hair long over the last 10 years but I
want to be real about something
something fake and that's hair
extensions the ones made from real human
hair the New Zealand Herald recently did
a really good article about the billion
dollar human hair trade where ponytails
are cut from a woman in the east and
sold to Western women for hair
extensions they told the story of one u
girl aged 14 from a poor village in
China here is a picture of her having
her ponytail cut off by a hair agent
that phrase itself sounds scary enough
this is someone who had offered her
family a small sum of money for her hair
elsewhere woman painstakingly pick apart
every strand of hair with their hands
can you imagine doing that it's
definitely not easy work and not all of
the hair has been cut off the head some
of it has been collected from hair
pulled out of hair brushes or even
collected from the street and of the
hair that is cut from the head not all
of it is taken willingly the hair agent
and the story told of girls who often
ran away crying as he tried to cut their
hair and had to be dragged back to his
song by their parents the hair trade has
been controversial since the early 1900s
when hair was reportedly collected from
sewers
taken from corpses who had died during
the plague in China
modern horror stories include woman
being held down by gang members and
having their hair taken or slum children
being tricked into haircuts for toys
some hair is ethically sourced and
willingly donated such as an Indian
temples where the woman cut off their
hair in religious sacrifice but this
hair is more expensive and the Chinese
hair is cheaper so is more popular by
the time hair extensions are hanging on
the wall of a salon like slabs of meat
all trace of their original owner has
been arrest I might look pretty entitled
standing here with such long hair and
telling other people not to get long
extensions you might say not only people
can grow their hair and while I'm not
talking to people who can't grow their
hair medical reasons I'm talking to the
girls who buy into transient beauty
trends inspired by people like the
Kardashians
we'll change their hair color and length
every month in today's culture when we
want something we want it now but hair
takes years to grow and it's that hard
work that makes it desirable in the
first place a lot of hard work is going
into hair extensions but it's for wrong
reasons I've done the work to grow my
hair long naturally and if you want long
hair then I think you should too if you
say your hair won't grow then stop
getting trims if you say you need to get
trims to cut off split ends then I'd
like you to know that what ends
eventually fall off by themselves anyway
by the time here gets this small all the
split ends have fallen off by themselves
so good luck